Casey is in Orlando Florida hi Casey
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
I was pretty distraught today and
decided to call you I and a graduate
from the University of Michigan I got
recruited to play Division one water
below
it's a was out of state for me I'm from
Orlando Florida I have about 175
thousand dollars with private student
loans and federal student loans combined
I'm a high school English teacher I've
been doing it for about three years and
I just really need to know what my next
step is because I'm in way over my head
I'm so confused you currently are a high
school English teacher yes sir and you
have a hundred and seventy-five thousand
dollars in student loans yes they're
added what does this have to do with
water polo I was recruited to play
Division one water polo for them and you
went there and it cost you one hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars to
play water polo
I did not get the money I was promised
and you kept on anyway
I don't quit I quit doing things all the
time that are stupid yeah it was my
passion and dream so now I'm paying for
it
hundred seventy-five thousand for water
polo Division one yes sir okay and so
now you make what a year I'm 38 five
okay um well I I not not to beat up on
you but I think it's going to be a
really good exercise and wisdom for you
to admit this was a dumb idea
regardless of whether it was your
passion yes you did not get a bargain no
this is not good for your life had you
to do it over you would not do it this
way please tell me that yes if I didn't
meet the love of my life I would I would
agree 100% period it doesn't cost others
$75,000 to meet the love of your life if
we harmony doesn't cost that much okay
you could go to school and meet the love
of your life and not go under
ninety-five grand in debt to play water
polo so we cannot in any way rationalize
this or justify this no it's not
beat you up but I you know it does help
you to go forward you need to have
learned the lessons now are you're
married to your love of your life not
yet
okay and are we engaged not yet not yet
how long you been out of school I'm four
years this is my fourth year out when
did you make the love of your life
and right before graduation okay ah did
you plan to get married do you think yes
sir
he's currently down in Florida with me
he went to Michigan as well okay and um
what does he make a year um he he was
trying to make the NFL he was with the
Saints he's currently looking for a job
himself okay and what was his de green
mr. green was on history okay all right
and how much student loan debt does he
have zero he was a football player for
the University of Michigan okay so that
worked out then okay um all right well I
think you're gonna at some point combine
your household income and and be able to
attack this but it's going to be a long
road until you get your incomes up
because 38 versus 175 you haven't got I
mean if you do ten thousand dollars a
year at 17 years okay and if you do 20
thousand dollars a year that's living on
literally beans and rice and then and I
know I'm not I'm okay with that but
that's still an eight or a nine year
process so you and he if he is your love
of your life in your future are going to
have to develop a game plan to get your
incomes way up and to attack this mess
so thanks for the call is this the part
of the show where I go and find her
parents and strangle them for not
parenting her while she's in college and
saying no you cannot do this why does
somebody that loves this girl not
interject themselves into our life and
say KC this is stupid you're going to
destroy the next decade of your life to
play water polo
175,000 dollars in debt while playing
Division one sports sport I mean this is
this didn't work out this didn't work
out and this is why we have a student
loan catastrophe in this country because
you have a government that will loan her
a hundred and seventy-five thousand
dollars no more on on this planet I mean
you really you if we if you have two
brain cells to rub together and you work
in a bank you wouldn't made this loan a
hundred and seventy-five thousand
dollars loan to an eighteen year old
unsecured debt that's going to be a high
school teacher
they make thirty eight thousand dollars
a year no one would make this loan in
their right mind but you and I as
taxpayers did because we deem education
so important that it does not Trump
stupidity
and it's just bless her heart I feel so
bad for her she's so freakin trapped
right now and no one in our culture her
parents her government her community and
her university all failed her
to teach her a that this was a really
dumb idea be that you need to have the
backbone and stand up and not do dumb
ideas and in the name of my passion but
we the people are loaning people like
this two hundred thousand dollars and we
wonder why we're going broke as a
country unbelievable